hello everyone how is it going I think
everything is on this time I like the
microphone and everything yesterday was
a little bit of a struggle that's all
good made it it's Thursday now close to
the end of the week and gamespot live is
back today we're gonna be playing some
resident evil 3 remake I'm pretty
excited it officially releases tomorrow
but we get a chance to play a little bit
of it today wanna help show it off I'm
actually picking up where generally
where the demo left off because I played
a little bit of the beginning to kind of
get us past the demo portion but a few
things are in a different order I guess
then the demo but if you want to check
out that demo portion we have another
let's play of that on the YouTube
channel right now so I did get you know
a little bit in not too far so there are
definitely a lot of little jump scares
in this and just getting to this point
right here I was already all over the
place but it's all good I'm excited to
actually play especially after playing
the demo and getting a little bit more
comfortable with it because I'm mostly
you know played like Resident Evil 5 and
so that obviously missed a huge wave of
Resident Evil games in the process you
know in terms of controls and stuff so
I'm excited to see this getting a chance
to kind of play the old ones even though
I may have missed the window so I just
got oh hold up hold up wait just gonna
tell you I just got to the part where I
grabbed the hose and I sprayed down the
fire but nemesis did not pop out and so
I came right into the next room and this
is where I paused so that's pretty much
where the the dimma left off so yeah
let's do it oh my goodness I'm already
like feeling the anticipation
I just picked up bolt cutters in hand if
you remember from the demo the bolt
cutters were like way earlier this is
where I came in from see all right and I
guess a 1 meter Oh actually I need to go
get the shotgun because I just got the
bolt cutters so let me go grab that real
quick I really hope so yeah you guys
probably remember all of this I'm still
not very good at um dodging these guys
with the little that I'm trying
cuz I already made some shoddy ammo but
yeah how are you guys doing happy
Thursday
welcome back sorry that little cutscene
they had where she was like it's someone
there it kind of freaked me out so I had
to focus for a second but let me just
grab this bad boy and then we're out a
can hello says I'm new how's it going
welcome hello from the UK what's up J
welcome thanks for tuning in
okay that's the same I've had better
shots than that alright and then I think
there was another grenade in here let's
see if it was something different in
this one Thank You Ward we're almost to
the end of the week okay you know what
I'm not ready for that right now
you guys relax we're just gonna continue
I have I have a good amount of ammo
right now I didn't need that anyways I
already have one hand grenade hopefully
I'll find another one in time I wasn't
mentally prepared Amparo
hello how's it going sorry if I said
that wrong horror fanatic from Marilyn
oh snap how's it going
they need to relax alright now that I
have the shotgun I feel a little bit
more confidence and breaking out whoever
is here I will say though that wasn't in
the demo the intro sequence is pretty
good but I'm kind of glad we're not
showing that part because it was really
good so when you guys play it I hope you
get a chance to see it I got scared for
a second hello what the [ __ ] he might
have been infected Oh stars be soft
killing your own people you would have
turned where's your sense of
self-preservation looks like Kevin from
Jaws like you know what wow just hating
on us for having emotions huh okay
also apologies in advance I get startled
very easily Tony already got jump script
like six times just getting to this very
beginning that we're still early on in
the game very early say like 20 minutes
our lesson
um you're not gonna oh I didn't want to
shoot this no I'm against this that's
messed up what up coughing cat has going
Roland says good luck and he just
finished it Wow all right well hey no
spoilers here I'm work I mean we might
run into you guys - no spoilers but we
at least kept the intro clear can I just
use this right away because I'm running
out of space crap alright first off yeah
I'm writing in caution so let me just
take this one and then pick this one all
right
can't believe I had to shoot that dog
that's gonna be a lot in this game from
all right now it's checking if there is
any barrels there I can never tell when
they're dead oh my goodness I've made a
mistake sugar brand bye
you know what you know what I get it I
get it
oh there's a lot of them is there
anything over here all right we gotta
trade it my neck my neck oh my god not
again get out of there get out of there
oh Jesus sweet oh crap this is what what
it's gonna be like for majority of this
I mean I gotta reload the shotgun whoo
all right gonna try to focus yeah just
in case let me just go for that quick
save right now all right sorry I'm like
trying not to die and also trying to say
hello oh wait she's here Thank You
Richie please help me Brandon what up
all right facts from substation chief
it's well employs violent outbreaks
across the city all right once the city
has been brought under control please
activate the four breakers as soon as
possible once that's done turn on the
main power switch in the control room to
reactivate the power grid
all right well I know for a fact we
haven't restored the power so should I
still try to do this I don't think I can
actually
oh this is telling me where it is all
right this is the door oh dang okay huh
all right so these are where they all
are
I'm gonna try to remember there's one
straight up I just don't know where
we're walking into this from so let's
see oh it stinks she definitely had me
feeling her pain right there oh there's
lots of herbs here green herbs they work
ill it's never gonna come back as well
so I put my hand there wolf all right
[Music]
and I need a backpack or something
there's another herb here I don't think
yeah that's already combined to re oh
well at least we know he oh crap I
probably should have a lock pick by now
wait what's that I don't trust this guy
who I wasted a bullet if he pops out of
me right now I swear no space for this
it's made a grave mistake oh my God all
of that all right hold them was there a
safe back the way we came
man I really don't think I need any more
ammo
huh I'm trying to think still ten rounds
I'm stocked right now I need that though
I have another ruby in my safe right now
we'll come back unless there's something
else I'm supposed to be getting from
here but I haven't picked up the
lockpick yet must be somewhere I must
have missed it oh you know what let me
let me shoot these fools up a bit faking
it
okay you need to go somewhere man this
guy's tanky and I don't believe that for
a second okay I do have to lockpick
where is it wait don't psych me out
because then it's not the case I have
not been using it
wait do I really have it already am I
just using the wrong button
yeah is everything running okay by the
way oh it's in that box all right I need
to hmm I need to drop something Ben
my inventory is just full crap need a
backpack oh here we go
yeah sorry um
thanks see the thing is I don't know
what I want to store most the time I
feel like I am gonna need this stuff oh
is this it
hip pouch okay yes I'm just an idiot and
I didn't walk to the right when I came
into the room all right I'll leave the
jewel in there for now now I'll go and
get whatever was in that box looking
it's not a guitar a cool thanks guys
because I am playing on PC so it should
be running smoothly it should be running
better than my console is usually do
alright now let me look
open it wait what happened well I can't
I Oh son
how do i what
the last box I picked up it totally
opened by itself oh there we go that's
so weird that the last one was like wah
wah wah bulge is opened all right now we
have locks to pick man there were so
many doors back in the beginning too I'm
sure we'll make our way back over there
what is this internal memo the key to
the high voltage area has gone missing
and the earliest we'll be able to get a
replacement in is next week in the
interim a lockpick will be provided to
the senior employee on duty we only have
one lockpick and cannot afford to lose
it so please keep it in its carrying
case at all times when you're not using
it
oh yeah no I should have read that first
all right let's try this bad boy out I
was like do I have to do it that would
be kind of cool
oh no okay whew I got scared me were you
in scary
yeah Oh
how how how herbs what do I do uh what
okay yeah seriously
oh here we are here we are okay I think
I remember okay there's one oh this is
you know I've been hunting trenches
lately an animal crossing all right I am
scared I ain't scared
I got herbs for days all right oh I
thought that was something
oh wait there's like a fast turn right
oh holy [ __ ] okay okay I ain't scared of
you come here I need the bills oh I
thought there was
hey buddy the thing is if he doesn't go
down in one hit though I actually might
be done so so let me let me ask it at
all don't tell me each one of these are
gonna be that was that
oh no wait I don't know
okay game I guess you know I knew once
that camera will happen it was about to
be bad
no maybe I should bring them over here
and just take them all out alright this
is a little bit more intense and I was
expecting it's a baby that's all good I
enjoy that I want more shot in with
Lucas
that was only one though
I don't want to leave yet I don't think
because I don't think the other ones are
up here right
Chadds notes those strange bugs hmm all
right
yeah okay there we KS handgun can hear
them alright good good good
Thank You Richie for the confidence I
just didn't want to get combo'd to death
as I was like puking up parasites and
also had this Oh
sneaky I kind of heard some squishing
around no nightmare please wait I keep
what's my 180 turn I know I asked that
already but I didn't look at the track
so I was flipping out Javier I am doing
well even though I'm getting scared
right now this is why I came all right
let me try this way oh alright there is
another one oh man
oh hi please
get away get away
yeah okay alright I will say aiming in
this game it's not my forte
Mike I don't we get it we get it this
camera angle with the like few seconds
to turn the thing is very is very
anxiety inducing so oh okay okay I heard
you I hear another one on my left I
think I knew it oh they're everywhere
whoa whoa whoa oh dang
can I get through this
oh man I'm hurting did I pass another
great green herb earlier this I don't
want to just use this one by itself down
and ash aha thank you
Thank You Richie oh I heard something
dewy
you trained the hip fire and no I should
not be doing that
did I do all four I was like there is
one more it's not unlimited ammo but I
did like have a ton of it before I got
to this point so one two three there's
one more I need to get through this part
to get to that one IRA Gurney's what
about this oh man I hear him I'm here up
[Music]
let's see
it's not open on the other side but a
grenade tryna think what is open over
there
go around or do I have to go up outside
and then down
so I can't go through there all right
try going up they might want me to go up
and I run my knife uh-oh
oh wait I don't want to either right now
spider boy out there
all right nice I'll know where you went
bout running oh oh my back oh I'm about
to die all right fine I'm gonna use it
but still hurtin my night oh I went to
toe oh my god oh it's disgusting down
all right nice what you guys said to use
the knife you've led me astray it's a
it's okay
I will be the tester oh wait here Spidey
boy run
I got Jill looking super junk right now
oh I have the squeakin let me try to go
up and explore and see if I can get down
on the other side somewhere
because I didn't see a way in oh yeah
this looks right you okay there we go
I hear them okay all right okay so far
she hasn't died all right not rest in
peace to Jill yet okay baby see maybe
soon Oh
no okay I definitely ran the wrong know
the last oh I forgot it climbed down
here oh wait they brought me back they
brought me back a nice nice nice sorry
let's get out of here
there was another herb here right
already picked it up huh okay all that
was mom's the file size for Mia for PC
was like 19 gigs
alright and with that I want to save
immediately I am hurting no more ammo am
I gonna need the red jewel for anything
immediately I don't know in there for
now Carlos its Joe I've restored power
to Subway okay we're going back to the
town where we got the house I think I
know the building not all right now
let's pick some locks
please please no zombies jump out at me
nothing
all right yeah I need some herbs I know
Jill I know I'm sorry
run gel please
ding all right season the right way no I
don't think it is snow I went the wrong
way
crap chillin sorry Jill I'm dead
literally read me crap that scared me
I saw me grenade all right I'm prepared
this time was about something I was not
there
oh boy run run run Barry let me not go
the wrong way up the stairs wait are
they not here anymore I would be so
convenient I was around the other side
kay-kay alright alright
Swiss like lightning oh come on no way
oh and then I knocked her up the stairs
that is not where Garland's help me
sweet Jesus
oh not until I get traffic control
online oh come on
this is not the time away I'm safe in
here okay please let there be a first
aid spray in here I swear I won't ask
for anything else this game yes alright
I said I won't ask for anything else's
game and and so I won't holy moly
alright subway station
oh hell I didn't pick up
oh wait I'm still running hold on I'm
going in the safe room over here because
I can't with this right now oh and
there's a lockpick right there wait I
hear him still alright he's not in here
he's not in here there's no way he's in
here
holy crap alright who had to collect me
oh go away go away nemesis I'm gonna
need to go outside for a second ok so I
definitely do not have time to pick this
lock
[Music]
oh come on come on man Oh Lord oh no I'm
getting hit with the combos right now
she's over here talking casual as if she
doesn't have nemesis straight running
after her closely the music calm down
but no way I don't have a grenade I was
too scared to go pick it up from that
ality earlier and now look at me
suffering where we okay
Fox break of Chris I'll be on the other
side oh yeah we can do that we can do
that oh all right little puzzle time
home
Oh interesting
one two three - oh boy
this looks
ari
oh no Ari's at the top is REE redstone
and then the last one yeah okay so we
need boss and then raccoon and then
[Music]
market No
okay that one is open saint-michel
Wow he's hunter that was scary
alright and then alright one two
it's like watered down but it looks like
three so I'm gonna go with that and then
think that's to root confirmed
yeah all right cool we did it
I have not played the multiplayer yet
DCCA but I want to check it out
return to the subway station you say all
right please give me something something
to make my life easier here all right
some shoddy shells Oh
anything else to pick in here would be
super useful right now we check the
shotty room hope you guys are enjoying
the game so far I guess his first day
it's free so like I'm using it a bit
early but you know what I can't be
playing these games I'd rather be safe
than be sorry later
I can hear a nemesis I'm saying alright
so oh now you want to get up what oh
dang it I just used that first aid crap
all right I'm trying to visualize where
was the
I have to go back through the donut shop
oh my god you over here factory donut
shop upstairs oh no oh no oh no I don't
want another one of those okay through
here up the stairs
oh no oh
[Music]
no no no he should have got electrocuted
too that was some BS there's no wait
which way was it oh it wasn't it was the
wrong way it was so wrong no no no
stomach degree crap
stress stress oh my god no man I wish I
had a grenade right now oh lordy we're
starting back here okay it's fine
because and get the Perseids free again
hopefully I won't get got come on I play
Marvel 3 I know I had a beat nimah sis
all right
craziness I tell you craziness spray it
down real quick
and we're out
oh no I forgot to reload okay
great deal with this again try to stay
as far away from that guy as possible
and read okay let's see if we can get he
jumped right on the door
that so my head ripping my pain out no
this is this is cool right now you guys
not right now
try to pull you zombies away like oh my
goodness I really don't know the optimal
dodge time
get up Jill she is getting destroyed
right now no run oh wait there it is
don't jump over here and then this is
its let me get through the door oh my
god I forgot about this guy Oh French Oh
run go alright sorry Joe
I've sailed holy crap alright they're
like you need some help I just don't
have the grenade all right this would be
a lot easier if I had the grenade ah
it's still pretty funny though all right
let me not forget to reload my gun this
time
I'm wondering if I should try to go back
to that album and see the thing is I
don't even know if they're goodnight is
still over there because things are
different from the demo it it might be a
business but if I'm running from nemesis
maybe he was locked in the plaza right
now if he's watching the plaza portion I
should be okay they go trade
yeah I felt like I was using this spray
pretty early oh there's a bunch of them
oh crap
we did this - all of them are ready cuz
I mean these ones up oh wait where is it
No
oh this is not good this is not good oh
there it is
I'm always walking the wrong way these
guys are still oh crap oh okay I first
hey it's great
okay oh my goodness there's so many of
them here and I know they're still alive
okay shotty shells hand grenade give me
all of that all right there's some hand
oh wait
all right I have the grenade
I'm going to use the electricity first
and then the grenades later if I really
really did
let's go let's go oh crap oh dang Oh why
should he use the spray before I
realized oh crap crap crap crap
this cruel cruel wait
oh it pauses holy alright I need to get
I need more space I need more space
before I can throw this
oh my God my dodging is not on point
oh goodness now he's gonna be too fat
for me to get by no okay I think I just
have to died really please oh please
yeah close that door a girl whoa yeah
that's um that needs to be saved
uh I thought I was a goner right there
Carlos boy oh man that store had a lock
on it - I wonder what was in that store
it definitely did not have no time to
stop and look but hopefully I'll get a
chance later
yo nemesis you're disrespectful bro
straight and disrespectful
nice job supercoppa I'm impressed you
did nothing Carlos but we need 30 or 40
minutes to finish maintenance
[Applause]
Nicholi how are you
holy man freaks no chance of fighting
around this why is she here she's helped
me get the trades running again had time
to start getting dead weight again pull
the trigger when it counts hey take it
easy
why should she go fight nemesis
one-on-one sorry about that
everyone's a little worked up yo wait oh
come on not again I thought we were in
saved here
it's me he's after what wait
Jill I did not agree to this
[Laughter]
uh oh my god he's just gonna bust all
these shelves down Here I am running
around looking like an idiot oh my
goodness
oh crap wait up stop it I need to get
you next to these barrels okay yeah
my chance uh and kick it down girl oh my
god he's about to grab your feet yank
you back out she is giving me anxiety
with these look these decisions
it's like that door looks nice and
secure but I don't know I don't know how
secure its really gonna be do you copy
Carlos yeah that's what happened when we
tried to be a hero oh yes some herbs and
a map cool a map of the area
perfect Oh My lordy this game's got me
sweating
another pouch I could go for that oh no
what is that
how do I get I don't want to pass that
out did I miss the door
it's not another durian here okay I just
had to make sure sometimes it's easy to
walk past the door you need it or
something especially because it's like
giving me uh air supposedly
okay need to go up
oh but it's a power source
hurry electronic locks special me
battery pack right gotta go find some
poor guys exploding body again
oh man it's dark down here
what is that oh my god what is that what
in the heck is that oh he's over here
[Music]
notice noticed and noted my map of the
area
if only the map told me I was about to
get chomped all right I thought it was
like the same one floating around but
now we got all all over here
get up there so that I can drop the
ladder
oh yeah Epps in the Chan
I don't know oh wait yeah there we go
so this way goes over there
there were stairs back here
huh
uh-huh haha
they put that ladder just out of sight
and no key cards than that Oh
all right well I didn't even have what I
needed for up here
whoa you're doing a little dance on the
ladder there they want me to go in there
hold man I feel like this isn't a good
idea
go up all right nice yeah that's what
I'm talking about
oh wait hold on I need to clear some
space uh how often do you think I'm
gonna go I did have a spot what what's
happening oh it takes two slots oh so I
have another urban here by chance okay
why is it want you to discard that oh I
thought I'd be able to make some grants
um you guys I just need one moment
please just give me one second
I mean one second you guys sorry
you
you
all right guys my bad sorry about that
how do you go handle something at door
real quick but we are best all right so
we got you a kind of a safe spot here
well I hear I'm outside I need to
organize my items a bit I mean just dang
I wish I had an herb or something why
does it want me to discard this I won't
I will put it just don't want to have to
use it I'm gonna be so sad if I have to
use it Oh cuz I picked that up there
to create flame rounds I supposed to be
a weak acid rounds interesting hello
kitty I'm doing well how are you doing
just playing some resident evil 3 remake
having a nice calm Thursday as calm as I
possibly again while having creepy
monsters right outside my door every
moment oh man alright hold up I am about
to in this whole man's career I got two
in the chamber one for you and one for
your homie were you in
it's gonna die though is the question
or is that only to stunned
you know what that is Jill he done
swallowed you whole last round got one
for your friend too oh wait I forgot
which side you came out of
Oh oh there you are hi burn
there we go we need to get some more of
those fire rounds immediately because
that was useful no no not like this I
was so confident five seconds ago he's
gonna come all the way over here is he
gonna stay in his Lane no the music
where I'm just gonna have to try to
dodge around him like last time oh he
went he went all the way home he saw his
friend here on the floor
great let's just trying to dodge oh crap
oh my goodness
what are you doing Joe alright this guy
area
I don't need the bolt cutters
alright put them away I don't want to
throw them away just want to put them
dang oh wait this is the others
oh my gosh I had to go back and do that
all over again
I didn't save in that other room
[Music]
nothing over here right
I'm definitely balanced
all right so I successfully dodged at
this guy cuz I dodged while he was like
falling out of the hole my back hurts
just watching that I dodged that no I
don't need a system ode or a game I just
don't know how to dodge correctly
ding
I'm so sad I have to do this again
[Music]
just kill him I can't I can't without
the fire grenade I don't have the fire
grenade yet let me try to use the
shotgun on him last time right I hit him
a couple times
[Applause]
oh all right
that was my fault that was my fault the
area I realized too late that I could
just shoot him in the mouth up the
reload yeah I lost it cuz I didn't save
in that room after I picked it up so let
me see how many shoddy shots to the
mouth can he take that is
[Music]
[Music]
Oh No he is so creepy like
alright alright yeah alright that's it
that's like five shots to the mouth but
I'll have two more flame grenades for
those other two which is good news
all right let me pick this bad boy up no
more games okay what was that thing I
just picked up gun shop the X X X X X X
grenade launcher made special
adjustments
okay recipes mine rounds can be readily
crafted and not worth stocking up on
won't help if we need the gammas online
interesting okay
oh let's go
yeah
Ram Reyes set these guys on fire
baby bird
[Applause]
now I'm ready for this guy unlike last
night
I feel like this games mostly about
being prepared so far for me is like I
don't know if the correct things get rid
of it I don't have much face now if I
run into another one of these guys I'm
done I think we might be okay aha yes
the bat oh no two slots for this - oh we
can't do it like that
me is this then I can get that and heal
up all right
I still need one more a love letter my
little darlings Oh crack this real quick
nice alright so I guess I can discard
this
oh wait wasn't there another backpack
somewhere close well I won't be able to
get there unless I don't have this one
huh last time I did not didn't realize I
had a backpack on the way
there we go all right we have the
battery
let's see what's waiting for us
please don't let there be any more those
things
Becky's Aaron oh no come on come on oh
wait wait I don't have my gurney hit
over here
burn
it sucks like a long dramatic death yeah
him bellies all jiggly all right so this
one we're not bad
oh my god
they're little agile I see yeah thanks
for hanging out with us you guys I do
feel like I'm trying my best but I get
scared so easily I have a battery for
this wait there was wasn't there another
door somewhere that had a battery did I
just waste this okay bang that I just
waste this better I felt like there was
another door oh I might have to go
through here because I think it was up
that ramp dang I see I see what they're
doing let's just see what's in here some
of the things look like you can pick
them up they can Oh
and I am now out
we fight like one
see there's that door I must have
another battery nearby hopefully ah
knock this down go back around that
means it's gonna be another one I think
please please please so jump on and then
there
huh
I'm trying to think can I keep reusing
the same one because I don't think I can
come back up here
there was a grenade there the whole time
yeah I don't I don't know if I can reuse
it at the same time that's locked all
right interesting
you guys rock for tuning in and bearing
with me ah ha
there we go
yeah so now I could take this out all
I've picked up that stupid grenade
ah crap
uh I really don't want to throw either
shotgun shells I don't throw away
anything right now
Oh hold on let me go in here real quick
dang why did I pick up that grenade oh
well sorry I'm gonna get rid of it just
like and hold this stupid battery I
[Laughter]
swear I'm not trying to scream your
guy's ears off but when I get jumpscared
it's it's real it's super real yes it's
unfortunate that I had to discard that
grenade but they're giving me some other
stuff so oh yeah take that too
wait okay so I've to so let's use slots
open for the key all right I think
that's all that's in here
yeah this Teagan I'll be so mad if I
worked somewhere and they only had like
one makeshift key for everyone to share
for all the doors because they didn't
have any to you okay I've got the key
where am I gonna go
going to their yeah I was like wait hold
up I got lost
classic survival horror problem right
there yeah not enough space they gave me
to backpack so so far so that's not so
bad
Carlos you didn't hear me now yeah I'm
alive I lost him as soon as I make it
back he say oh wait I heard the feet
first and I tried to look I don't know
what happened there
no no no all right they have to lunge at
me first and then I have to dodge I
think ow
yeah that is the end of it girl and you
know it I couldn't use weapons great
that's not very he's already scary as
heck
okay all right I got three explosive
rounds now
so I guess I didn't really need the
grenade Oh we are absolutely saving this
it's been a little while do not like
feeling a bit see you later Brandon
thanks for tuning in hanging out alright
let's test this oh I did you really
honestly I think to like I just didn't
have the space all right
what Oh
yeah for sure
I agree Joan
he
now hold mommy - wow they fell so
perfectly is this fool like right behind
me where am I going
where am I going Oh No
what
and my oh there it is how did I not see
that ladder the first time
he looks kinda cool though he does
rolling up
looks like a doom eternal stage oh yeah
where are you kidding me he's setting
the whole place on fire
all right we're just going up
nemesis with the flames
Wow
that upper-body strength though
this play what's a savior notice of
demolition day
just in case
just because they offered it I feel a
boss fights come around oh now my
prepared I'm prepared I have three
explosive rounds I have some shoddy
animals
I need to shoot the tank on his back I
feel like it's full of fuel
did that do nothing I hit him with it
directly man I wasted one I'm very sad
about it
oh I definitely
oh this is not good this is not oh
alright it's fine
I somehow wasted that first one that
first round because I don't know what
you know it's the halo in me that says
hey you have a rocket launcher so you
should shoot it at the ground and make
the rocket explode but not direct impact
I see I see
oh boy
here we go
crap no above fire wow i'm literally
burning to death I have to try this
again after this he thought shirt what
are these oh there's an electric things
looking for some sort of barrels or
something
it's okay Jill for the cause
- I all right you're gonna rear and grab
this and then try - oh wait that was the
one I grabs crap
don't have explosive
on fire oh there's more round sir ayyy
nice oh I need to reload nope no now I'm
on fire again
[Music]
okay now I run now I get out Wow like
where am I going
still kicking yeah word what what
and you're putting fire everywhere
oh wow the fact that she's still alive
after that is phenomenal
oh I'm sorry Jill I'm so sorry I have
fail
oh my goodness looking good what is that
shoddy [ __ ] okay there's just so much
fire oh no I don't want to electrocute
myself all right one more time around
the loop-d-loop
okay okay got it
noted mm-hmm dang is tanky
all right the goal I think I don't know
what the goal is let's be real here
you sure about that Jim you sure that's
what you want
ooh seeing if maybe I could explode that
thing
why
[Music]
so my nemesis du Soleil Wow okay yeah so
that's not the time I should cheer to
you Oh
all right so only one is
crap
like I wasted those
[Music]
the fuel tank okay oh god oh god not
right now Jill not right now okay all
right so the fuel tank noted
she's hurt and
straight up on fire pick up some
explosive rounds who's trying to pick up
the explosive rounds alright so shoot
the tank fast does the tank only die -
um like the shotgun shells ooh can I
blow it up with the explosive rounds
I'll just keep the shotty out first if
that's the case
yeah
getting angry getting angry
and you get in Cologne
shoot so big can't get around him
can you definitely get these
[Music]
better now nemesis
oh my god what did I not just pick up oh
my goodness
alright fine Tommy picked up shoddy
shows
Wow and then he dodged it I can't with
this guy
Wow all right so I'm not wasting any
more of those I don't know how last time
I love this tank so quickly
there we go sheesh I'm like
like still kicking
I don't know guys I really don't know
oh you Oh No
Wow course
my goodness
this music is like
oh my god nightmare currency
I was already struggling I just didn't
know if my handgun was he's gonna do any
damage the way you dodged my grenade
though was so so swift
so tactical oh I'm struggling Carlos
where you at bro dang I am fighting for
my life
oh wow on the glass I will say I'm very
happy I have not run into a single
QuickTime event aside from like those
zombies jumping on you inviting you but
like in the cutscenes because they're so
action-packed I would be missing them
all the time oh we got him he had the
moves but we got him but nemesis down
question work no that was definitely not
enough Jill do you read me no yeah
that's no it's not I'm a hero
don't start I did what I had to
wait hold up they don't want me to go
like oh that risk that's not say I'm not
going all the way back through I
couldn't even get up there anyway if I
fell off I'm extra lost right now oh oh
no way I have to go back through which
probably a door over here
psych Wow where am I
saloon so lost can I climb up or go
around whoa where am I
I at least want to make it back to the
subway before I in in the stream but
with with my sense of dread this is the
other thing too I have no sense of
direction whatsoever I even have a map
and still in no sense of direction
Oh is there a subway station
can't go over that debris apparently all
right 12 that is our time I seriously
cannot find out how to get out of here
right now so I don't want to waste any
more moments of times the fire truck
wait I walked up to it all right let me
just go see I must see you now unless I
didn't run up the right side of it oh
yeah thank you thank you all right you
guys but still gonna be ending it right
about here thank you guys so much for
tuning in and hanging out with us as
always we are live every single weekday
at 2:00 p.m. Pacific time and I hope you
guys had fun
resident evil I really like this series
I think it's crazy
and funny and I'm really glad that
they've come out with all these remakes
because I don't know I just think it's
really cool a good chance to kind of
catch up with the series now so yeah
thank you guys so much for tuning in
come back tomorrow for some community
Fridays with a John Luke and Ben until
then we will see you guys next time
peace bye